foreign
Kardashian and Pete Davidson due date
night PDA style the lovebirds were
snapped out and about in Los Angeles on
Tuesday night holding hands and wrapping
their arms around each other I love that
that's the 41 year old kkw beauty
founder rocking a gray hoodie black
leather pants with matching boots and
that's the 28 year old Saturday Night
Live star keeping it casual in a black
cap light gray zip up Hoodie t-shirt
patterned pants and sneakers and that
that right there is some serious
hand-holding people at the end of the
day life is about being happy according
to an eyewitness the two snuck out the
back door of Italian Hot Spot John and
Vinnies after enjoying a little pizza
the duo also made a quick stop at a Rite
Aid Pharmacy to pick up some ice cream
before heading home for the night from
the looks of it things appear to be
getting serious between Kim and Pete and
a source recently dished to eat T about
why their relationship Works quote he
makes her laugh plays around and has a
sense of humor it is nice for Kim to be
around that I love that energy in my
life and on top of all that ET sour says
Pete knows how to talk to Kim explaining
quote he is the most confident guy but
not cocky it is why it works with them
Kim thinks Pete is super sexy and likes
how he knows so much about comedy since
that is a world she doesn't know as much
about it's a different experience for
sure as for Kim's ex Kanye West he's
been spending lots of time with uncut
gemstar Julia Fox on Wednesday the two
were spotted hanging out at La hotspot
Delilah with some major star power
including Madonna Floyd Mayweather and
Evan Ross Evan posted a few pics and
clips from the group hang on Instagram
and that right there that's the 44 year
old Grammy winner and the 31 year old
actress cuddled up on the couch and yes
that's Julia with her arms around yay
the two were also spotted leaving the
venue hand in hand and brace for some
serious smooching because they puckered
up for the cameras laying a big old kiss
on each other of course this all comes
after the two packed on PDA in New York
City during their second date which was
documented by interview magazine Kanye
and Julia took in a show followed by
dinner and capped the night off in a
hotel suite full of clothes it was
really surreal and Julia she dished on
the romantic night telling the mag quote
I was so surprised like who does things
like this on a second date or any date
everything with us has been so organic I
don't know where things are headed but
if this is any indication of the future
I'm loving the ride
[Music]
thank you